jonglage contorsion univers gothique
lancé de couteau les poustouflantes
compagnie suédoise Circus circor nous
propose une plongée circassienne dans
les profondeurs du cerveau avec le
spectacle where it like a crown présenté
du 18 au 23 décembre au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline pour nous en
parler voici l'agent québécois de la
compagnie Vincent messagers qui nous en
parle depuis le Québec par internet
c'est parti
j'étais 12 ans l'agent de l'agent le
chargé de qu'on appelle un agent Québec
je vous vous appz ça un chargé de
diffusion donc c'est moi qui a été à la
base de 12 dernières années de tout le
développement du circoise en France
alors je me suis un petit peu donné la
mission de faire connaître le Tr
travaille de Circus Secor en France en
Belgique et en
Suisse CIRC CCOR c'est en fait une
compagnie qui a été créée par une dame
qui s'appelle tilde bios force tilde
venait du du milieu des es de la rue en
Suède et en 1994 elle a décidé de venir
à Paris voir ce qui s passait et elle a
découvert un univers qu'elle ne
s'attendait pas de découvrir qui est
univers du nouveau cirque elle a décidé
de rentrer chez elle et de faire
connaître le nouveau cirque au Suédois
donc elle a commencé par créer d'abord
une école et tranquillement ils ont fait
leur premier spectacle un an plus tard
qui a été un très grand succès euh le
téléphone s'est mis à sonner les
programmateurs suédois ont fait
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça on a jamais
entendu parler de ça et la compagnie
toujourd'hui une compagnie très réputé
en Scandinavie ils sont vraiment à
l'origine de tout le mouvement du
nouveau CIRC qu'il a dans les pays Nord
actuellement like Crown c'estectivement
la dernière partie d'une trilogie where
like
Crown deux prémisses de base il y a la
prémisse que le cerveau droit et le
cerveau gauche ne fonctionne pas de la
même manière le cerveau gauche on sait
le cerveau créatif donc tilde elle a
toujours accompagné son travail par une
recherche de fond avec des scientifiques
avec des artistes et puis des
neurologues et cetera pour en arriver
finalement à développer son idée de de
de création la deuxième prémisse c'est
que dans la vie chaque individu porte
ses angoisses ses tourments ses peurs et
généralement on en est tous un peu gêné
tild dit non il faut pas être gêné de
nos peurs faut pas gêner nos tourments
il faut les porter fièrement comme une
couronne
chaque individu est plus ou moins
confronté dans le spectacle à ses
angoisses à ses peurs à ses limites et
seulement apprend à les porter comme une
couronne c'est une couronne géante qu'on
va voir sur scène de laquelle partent
les les numéros aériens CC c'est une
compagnie qui ont une imaginaire très
unique a eu avec des personnalités des
personnages très typés c'est des gens
carrément sortis d'un film de Tim Burton
euh attends on va le dire à la française
de Tim Burton on a effectivement comme
je disais un lanceur de couteau butau il
y a une contorsionniste qui fait aussi
du cersceau aérien qui est très très
forte qui qui a passé plusieurs années
au Québec à travailler avec des artistes
québécois il y a un duo qui fait du
alors c'est un duo qui font la jonglerie
avec des balles de ping-pong et ils sont
extraordinaires euh et ils font aussi de
du trapèze fixe il y a un personnage
clownesque et il y a une une
équilibriste
fragile la musique a été composée par
une une vedette du du des musiques
émergentes en Norvège une dame qui
s'appelle Rebecca cariolde qui est en
fait une artiste signée chez Sony
rebecca est une amie personnelle de de
tilde bios for et tilde quand elle l'
rencontré Rebecca et Rebecca lui a fait
écouter une chanson qui s'appelait we it
like a crown tild a non seulement trouvé
de la musique pour son spectacle mais a
trouvé le titre du
spectacle bienvenue et puis à la
prochaine on espère que vous viendrez
voir ça
nombreux
ouf et pour se remettre de nos émotions
voici un tout nouveau sujet de la
rédaction le grand public l'a découvert
dans la comédie musicale Les 10
commandements de Pascal Obispo le
chanteur Pablo Villafranca se produit
aujourd'hui dans un spectacle à
dimension humaine il prête sa voix à la
compagnie vinoise l'aventurine pour un
compte àien danse théâtre chant et
cirque sur scène ils sont 12 artistes
nous l'appellation qu'on lui a donné
c'est compte acrobatiquement musical
voilà et c'est effectivement
pluridisciplinaire ça mélange le chant
le théâtre les arts du cirque la magie
la danse allez laisse pas passer ta
chance prends ton sac à et
vasy c'est l'histoire d'Adrien qui est
un ancien clown devenu SDF parce qu'il
s'est passé un drame dans sa vie et qui
en
fait parce que il y a un CIRC qui
s'installe à côté de lui va petit à
petit revenir vers sa vie d'avant donc
c'est toute l'histoire et tout le
cheminement justement un peu le le
paradoxe entre le clown qui est un
personnage qui fait plutôt rire qui
inspire confiance le côté très positif
de ce personnage et le personnage du SDF
qui lui dans l'inconscient collectif a
quelque chose beaucoup plus négatif
l'histoire originale de ce compte drôle
et touchant et signé mode Bettina Marie
auteur pour la télévision elle présente
quotidiennement une émission de de
jeunesse sur le câble au théâtre elle
met en scène les artistes qui donnent
naissance à ces textes moi je suis
vraiment dans la direction d'acteur dans
l'intention et Cera et il y a la
chorégraphie à côté après le but c'est
de de tout mettre ensemble de tout
rassembler pour pour justement avoir un
spectacle fluide en fait qu'on voit un
ensemble et je pense que c'est ça qui
sort du l'eau en ce moment c'est ce côté
magique grand sor du terme en fait c'est
le côté spectacle en fait il y a pas
c'est pas une pièce de théâtre ou du
chant ou non c'est on voit un spectacle
entier quoi pour découvrir Adrien où la
vie en équilibre trois dates à retenir
les 11 12 et 19 janvier à la salle
blanche de Castille à
poissie et encore quelques dates à
retenir avant de faire vos derniers
achats de Noël vous retrouverez little
match seller la petite marchande
d'allumette adaptée par Nicolas Liotard
le 22 décembre à la ferme de bbas et le
duo clownesque de P pit le 23 décembre à
la Maison de l'environnement des dates
que vous pouvez retrouver ainsi que
l'ensemble de la programmation des
salalles cquentinoises sur le kiosque
sur Internet aux adresses qui
s'affichent et n'oubliez pas cette
semaine sur le
www.kiosque.ski.fr vous pouvez gagner
des places pour le spectacle Charles
Gonzalez devient à la Maison de la
poésie de
Savel le de la balle